hi guys my name is Tamara chambers and
look at all the cats on my body wow this
is Tamara's never seen and today I'm
watching jingle all the way
another Arnold film oh goody jingle all
the way it was the last session of notes
in my notebook who wants to buy it 500
dollars you'll get so much great content
like oh my god this can jump off a cliff
this all puppets no humans yes then she
gets attacked by a raptor squalene
really good notes here no regrets jingle
all the way oh camera's never seen that
was such a 90s Christmas movie so they
opened up on turbo man and booster which
is like a show for kids and booster the
sidekick looks like a sad version of a
pepto-bismol bottle of he was a furry
not sure why the bad guy in this
universe is just dropping kids off of
cliffs but turbo man saves him movies
already so 9 DZ oh I work too much it's
Christmas I'm gonna miss this important
event in my kid's life honestly though
it's just a karate class that he's gonna
miss I mean I understand that he wants
his father to be there to see it but
maybe invent something or become famous
so of course Arnold doesn't make it
Jaime's karate class and I mean
obviously duh duh of course you did it
to make it of course he didn't dodging
me down so yeah that's Jaime what do you
can get him for Christmas to make up for
it and Jaime's like all I want is this
turbo man doll dad it's kind of a weird
sketch here where Jamie goes into like
the turbo man spiel and I guess it's cuz
he's watched the commercial so many
times like turbo man action figure with
ultra noise box and a great wings and
that is not good it's odd it's so like
not the kid isn't like this quirky kid
like he's a very plain and regular kid
so for him to just do this really weird
yelling bit that doesn't really land is
okay hi Wendy are you gonna join me for
the review like my cat sure don't you
so now Arnold has to get this toy on
Christmas Eve that's impossible to get
how original then you meet Todd who's
the next-door neighbor who's apparently
this wonder dad
and so Arnold is like leaving his
driveway to go get a doll and Todd's
showing him this actual reindeer that he
got for his son for Christmas it's like
I just wanted to believe in Santa it's
an actual reindeer yeah it's whatever
Arnold's like what are you gonna do with
the reindeer after Christmas is over and
he's like well I've been watching this
group of regular deer out in the
countryside I think I'll release it to
them like I think that's supposed to
sound like a good thing that's just
definitely not how that works the
ecosystem is very like like specific on
what it needs and what it has and if you
enter in this new life-form that's not
from around it's just gonna fall
everything up so all right Todd Ted
Todd Ted I don't remember it's one of
those guess we'll find out in the
comments so he goes to the first store
to find the doll meets up with Sinbad is
also trying to find the doll
tell the store clerks that they're
trying to find the doll and they all
laugh at him and one of the store clerks
is the hilarious doctor from 30 rock
which I love and then the chase begins
oh sorry Wendy I scared her so much
yelling Tara calm down send dad so him
insane bad try unsuccessfully to get a
doll of this new place and they have
this weird like fight friendship going
on him and Sinbad do so Arnold his
character name is Howard Howard gets
into this SUV with this CD mall cop to
go and get a black market doll for his
son they end up going to this warehouse
is full of Santa's this weird Santa's
and it's like this black market Santa
shop but like why do they have to be
wearing Santa costumes they're just
making toys illegally I feel like that
just hinders them in so many ways tell
them a doll but it's $300 and it's also
broken and bilingual
the broken is terrible but bilingual
it's pretty actually helpful I wish I
knew two languages i wish i even knew
english all the way so then he fights a
bunch of santa's a in course he does
like why are you gonna cast arnold
schwarzenegger as a dad you're not don't
cast him as a dad
oh he's gonna find a bunch of Santa's
okay that's fine that'll work yeah no
it's totally cool
yeah good good so the police show up to
this black market Santa Store and break
it up and he finds like a fake badge in
one of the toy bins and he shows it to
them and gets out of the arrest which is
really cool I love that part funny in
his own little Arnold way I wish that
worked for me I'm a lion tamer chef I it
says it right here so I am I don't know
if that means that I'm a lion tamer
who's also a chef or if I'm like the
chef for a lion tamer also if I could
have chosen anything that's my chose if
you buy my notebook you also get
distinction then his car breaks down and
instead of going home he decides to
spend his time in a diner and then
Sinbad shows up because 90s writing then
they get drunk because 90s writing then
this whole weird scene happens where
this radio contest is like the first
caller gets one of the dolls the same
one you're looking for
hooray and so they call but then Sinbad
Yanks the phone line out because he
didn't get to be the first caller and so
then they run to the radio station and
still no one has called in for this very
highly wanted doll she's pretty weird
and he's like I'm here I get to claim
the doll that's not how that works you
didn't call in you don't get to claim
the doll Arnold and then the guys like I
don't even have the doll I said you
would get a doll I didn't say one you
would get a doll and then student Bad's
like I have a bomb wait what what excuse
me and then it turns out that it's not a
bomb and then the same cop shows up to
take care of the bomb incident and the
ends up being a bomb and it blows them
up it's not a very good bomb because it
just kind of scorches his face a little
bit
you see him later in the movie he's fine
so no worries it's just just a fun bomb
it's not one of those mean ones fun just
fun bomb the bud the Arlen comes home
sees Ted putting the star on the tree in
his family's house he's like you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna go steal
Ted's kids doll under their tree see how
he likes it and he's like I can't steal
from a kid that's ridiculous then he
sets fire to his home mess you're a mess
and then the mom gets mad they go to the
parade and he decides to instead of like
chase his family and say hey sorry
decides to sit on the back porch of
Ted's house drinking with the reindeer
he gets the reindeer drunk because again
90s writing duh of course he gets the
reindeer drunk I'd be disappointed if he
did it it's a lot of day drinking in
this movie not judging I'm just stating
the facts
somehow Arnold gets himself into this
predicament where he's playing turbo man
in the parade like it doesn't even
explain it well he just like walks into
the wrong room and they're like oh
you're here grab a q-tip it's so 90s
it's so 90s this movie has been really
fun for me to watch but it also is just
like oh my god every possible 90s cliche
that there ever has been is in this
movie and so it's fun to look back on
but it's also just like oh my god oh my
god oh my god it's my head red now
clip-clip oh it's right
intimidating intimidating intimidating
very intimidating so cut to him playing
turbo man in the local parade and he's
like I'm nervous oh I can get into this
it's so funny
and then he as turbo man gets to choose
a kid to come up and get a doll for
Christmas and it's really cute
and he chooses Jamie and it's Norville
he's like you know my name turbo man
knows my name
then Sinbad shows up dresses the
Dementor turbo man's nemesis and punches
Arnold off of the float and like it's
like this is some extreme links home
down buddy
whoa so then there's this whole chase
scene between Sinbad and Jamie and
Arnold and Jamie's like climbing to the
top of these really tall buildings and
like super brave kid is super brave must
be all those karate classes then it ends
up that Arnold has a jetpack what the
hell
what kind of budget is this local per a
to have I wrote ven turbo man uses his
jetpack yes that's right jetpack most
high budget local parade ever but okay
so he saves Jamie after using all of his
turbo man gadgets like his turbo rang
again okay he brings Jamie back to the
mom and they don't know that it's Howard
they don't know this arnold
schwarzenegger and the reveal would be
really cute when he's like it's actually
your father if it wasn't so ridiculous
he has such an obvious accent and also
the mask only covers half of his face
and it's see-through so it's obviously
clearly him and he's like hello I'm
Arnold Schwarzenegger and I am turbo man
and they're like who could it be so
you've been married to him for how long
how do you not know it Sinbad gets
arrested and Jamie gives him the doll
that he just got and Arnold's like what
the man thought you wanted that
doll I did a lot for this today and he's
like why do I need this
doll when I have the real turbo man at
home oh my god 90s just threw up
everywhere like yeah it's a very nice
sentiment but tomorrow when you wake up
and all of your friends have the doll
and you don't you're gonna be pretty
bummed because your dad still works the
same hours that he always worked it's
not like he's gonna show up every day to
play turbo man with you now I mean you
would like to hope that that that
happens he changes for the better but
you don't know there's no follow up to
this there's no jingle all the way to or
he's to stay-at-home dad playing turbo
man all the time
also synthase going to jail he can't
even give the doll to his kid anyways
he's just getting worse and worse like
not only does he not have the doll for
his kidneys he's gonna be in jail now
just so many family issues going on haha
like I said earlier I did I really
enjoyed it it was super fun to watch um
but I think just so easy to make fun of
because these are the kind of movies
that I kind of grew up watching I guess
I guess not because I didn't see this I
didn't see like home loan and stuff
anyways guys check out my personal
channel I posted a video there yesterday
I post one there every Friday and I will
see you guys next week
[Music]